الولد دويري اذا الان نحن امام رويتين
روايه ايرانيه تقول بان الاضرار اقتصرت
على سقف المبنى بينما الروايه الاسرائيليه
بحسب مراسل اكسيوس عن مصدر الاسرائيلي
بانه تم استهداف اربعه مواقع مختلفه في
المنشاه باصفهان وجميع الضربات حققت
اهدافها بمتابعتك بمتابعتك لصوره الانفجار
طبعا الذي الذي وصلنا على الاقل ما الذي
يمكن ان تكون حققته هذه الضربه من اضرار
في هذا المبنى الذي لم يعرف حتى الان ما
اذا كان يستخدم للمسيرات ام ل- ال- اا
صواريخ البالستيه
يعني الصوره التفجير لا تستطيع من خلالها
لانها صوره محدوده وانفجار يبدو للوهله
الاولى بانه اقرب الى الالعاب الناريه
لم يعني لا يعطيك صوره انفجار قوي الصوره
التي شاهدناها وتعرف لا تعطيك ذلك
الانطباع بان هناك انفجارا قويا لكن هذه
هذه الصوره لا يمكن اعتمادا لكن دعني اقول
الان الفجوه التاسعه ما بين الروايه التي
قدمتها ايران
والمعطيات التي قدمت من من العديد من
المصادر وموقع ولا او اكسس او ما شابه ذلك
ويعزز الميل بالاتجاه الاخر اجتماع همم
لجنه الخارجيه والامن في مجلس النواب
الايراني لتقييم الضرار
وبالتالي تحديد اليه لكن دعني اقول حتى
هذا الانفجار الذي يشاهدنا الان لا ي- لا
يعتبر لا يعتبر ضربه فاعله مؤثره حتى وان
كانت همم اربعه مواقع درون ما لم تكن همم
استنادا الى يعني جزئيه انها من دروب انها
من درون ستبقى هم لسه محدوده الان حتى انت
تؤثر همم في مصنع من بديهيات بديهيات
انشاء مصانع همم تكون منشا واضح معامل
دفاع
يجب ان تكون محسنه ولو كانت فوق الارض
محصنه بصوره ضد القنابل